-Performing "Yes, I'm a Mess"
from their album
"The Maybe Man," which is out
right now -- it is out --
once again, AJR!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ I leave my house
at 3 o'clock ♪
♪ With 200 texts
and two missed calls ♪
♪ Guess all of the friends
that I pissed off ♪
♪ All talked ♪
♪ And I took a job
for just July ♪
♪ But feels like I might be here
for life ♪
♪ Yeah, I'm in it now ♪
♪ I'm in it now ♪
♪ Could I start again somehow? ♪
♪ Yes, I'm a mess with an S on
my chest ♪
♪ Got stress filling up
my head ♪
♪ So I spent last night ♪
♪ Blowing up my life ♪
♪ Now you won't see me again ♪
♪ Cheers to the front
and cheers to the back ♪
♪ And cheers to the 2010s ♪
♪ I could hate my guts
when the sun comes up ♪
♪ But I like myself like this ♪
♪ I like myself like this ♪
♪♪
♪ Why should I fix the things
I've done ♪
♪ When I could just pack
my things and run ♪
♪ Delete every number
from my phone ♪
♪ So long ♪
♪ Yeah, I'll get new shirts
'cause mine all stink ♪
♪ And I'll tell my boss
what I really think ♪
♪ Yeah, I'm in it now ♪
♪ I'm in it now ♪
♪ Could I start again somehow? ♪
♪ Yes, I'm a mess with an S on
my chest ♪
♪ Got stress filling up
my head ♪
♪ So I spent last night ♪
♪ Blowing up my life ♪
♪ Now you won't see me again ♪
♪ Cheers to the front
and cheers to the back ♪
♪ And cheers to the 2010s ♪
♪ I could hate my guts
when the sun comes up ♪
♪ But I like myself like this ♪
♪ I like myself like this ♪
♪♪
♪ Yes, I'm a mess with an S on
my chest ♪
♪ So I spent last night ♪
♪ Blowing up my life ♪
♪ Now you won't see me again ♪
♪ Yes, I'm a mess with an S on
my chest ♪
♪ I could hate my guts
when the sun comes up ♪
♪ But I guess that's
what this is ♪
♪ I like myself like this ♪
♪♪
♪ I could hate my guts
when the sun comes up ♪
♪ But I like myself like this ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]